[Music]
so religion has become more influential
in global politics and it really started
taking off in the 1970s whereas you know
people today if you read contemporary
newspapers and magazines and journals
and stuff you would think that it all
started in the post 9/11 era that as a
result of 9/11 people started noticing
or always thought that religion that's
where it really took off but it actually
really started taking over the 1970s and
there's a three-fold story to it the
first is is the failure sort of of the
post-colonial regimes in the 1960s and
70s so you understand these are states
that got independence from after World
War Two and they were given a chance at
sort of directing their states as
running their states these are people
you can think about Gandhi
and others who were educated in the West
go back to their countries and bring
ideas Western sort of ideas out of the
university systems Cambridge Oxford
Harvard Tufts and and and tried to
implement those ideas at home and they
failed and so by the 1960s in the 1970s
you start seeing failed failed and
failing States emerging and populations
sort of challenging their statesmen and
saying why is it you you're supposed to
be the one providing for the basic goods
and services for my society and for me
why are you failing and so they started
challenging political authorities and
helping them to challenge them was
church leaders and religious ideas
because religion many religions are
based on the idea of justice and
equality and there were some things that
have in the 1960s the Catholic Church
started talking about the Equality of
all people all people deserve human
dignity not just Catholics and so
religious actors were there with some
ideas and they were also not fully de
legitimated in the way in which
mainstream secular political actors were
and so they helped to propel sort of a
set of ideas and a set of activities
that challenged States so though it was
sort of the collapse of the
modernization theory that this was all
going to lead to good the end of poverty
end of disease and of war it didn't and
religious actors were there to be able
to to capitalize on that to help they
were there to help both clergy
Bishop's but also laypeople who were
part of different churches and this is
across different faith traditions it's
just not the Catholic and Christian
faith tradition
we're also within the Muslim community
Shia were reinterpreting what it meant
to be Shia among Muslims that they
needed to be more politically active and
this sort of led to reinterpretation of
doctrine and it culminated in the 1979
revolution where they felt that they had
the right actually the obligation to
overthrow the Shah who was a secular
leader and bring about Sharia law within
Iran right and so it wasn't just a
Christian so that was one failure
modernization and religious actors there
to be able to help the people who were
struggling and suffering within these
societies under autocratic regimes the
second is is a democratization it's
related to it that you do see an
increase in the number of countries
globally after the 1970s democratize so
voices and ideas similar to the religion
were being voiced and and put into power
so democratization helped propel
religious ideas into the into the global
and political arena and lastly as
globalization religious actors are
transnational actors their ideas and
their people they're they're they're
their personnel traveled the globe why
does the Pope travel the Pope travels
because his church is made of his church
members that is what constitutes the
church and he needs to go visit them you
know when home a knee was you know
thinking about the Revolution and
changing the Iranian government
he had digital cassette tapes that he
sent from Paris he was in exile in Paris
in the 70s and he sent them back to
Tehran and so as a transnational actor
right he had ideas that were flowing
across this community
similarly the Catholic Church john paul
john pope ii you know going around
eastern europe in the 1980s and
basically wagging his finger at these
regimes saying you need to do better by
your people you have an obligation these
people are relying on you and so this
this globalization of ideas and movement
of people really helped propel religious
ideas into the global
rina and empowered domestic level actors
to be able to challenge their states and
their regimes and they did we're now
it's 2017 and religious actors are not
going anywhere and if anything you know
they're becoming stronger we now have
this fight against Isis you can look at
votes around the world people want
religious actors to have a say in
politics they don't want religion to
necessarily be a private matter
that it should be and needs to be part
of the public discourse this is a change
this is a big change from where we were
in the 1960s and 70s where the idea was
secularism separating religion from the
private that the public space the public
square you were not allowed to end this
was a global phenomenon I mean you and
you can think about the Eastern Bloc
they were atheistic regimes they they
cut religion out of the entire system
but then with the end of the Cold War it
came back and so orthodoxy is now
married again with the Russian state and
then around the world you're seeing this
demand to have more and more religion
religious ideas as part of public policy
[Music]